well this is one of the saddest and most
momentous turning points in the history
of the united kingdom
there's nobody in this country
or the world who hasn't lived the
majority of their lives
under the reign of queen elizabeth ii
for 70 years she served this country was
astoundingly dedicated duty
i struggled to even imagine a britain
without this queen
but with great sadness we now have to
imagine it because the moment we've all
been dreading has finally come
and tonight everything changes her death
is an enormous blow not just to the
british people
but to our national psyche
to people around the world who don't
fully understand our deep affinity with
this queen it's as simple as this
our monarchy and her majesty are the
very essence of being british
as abraham lincoln apple pie and the
constitution art of being american
so the royal family is to great britain
more than an institution it's an
identity it's who we are
it's the magna carta the palace of
westminster the battle of waterloo
it's austin dickens shakespeare the
beatles it's crushing the nazis it's
churchill and the blitz spirit
it's royal ascot and the chelsea flower
show cricket at lords wimbledon tennis
football at wembley
nothing and nobody has symbolized what
it means to be british
better than queen elizabeth
she's always been there
she had an aura of invincibility that
sadly today has been shattered and now
we have to learn as a country to live
without her
whatever your views of the royal family
wherever you live in the world
you will remember this day because it's
history unfolding before our eyes
this remarkable little lady was not just
our longest serving monarch she was the
second longest reigning monarch in all
of history she appointed 15 british
prime ministers she hosted 13 of the
last 14 american presidents she was our
queen for 30
of america's entire history think about
that
she held more than 100 state visits for
the world's leaders she was the head of
state herself
in 17 countries she was the head of the
commonwealth of nations
and she guided us all through the best
of times and the worst of times through
wars terrorism pandemics
natural disasters financial crises
whatever it was she was there with
dignity duty stoicism and that famous
stiff upper lip
our last act this week was to appoint
our new prime minister remarkably
staggeringly she was dutiful until the
very very end
i'm so very glad and so very grateful
that we all have had the chance to say
thank you at her platinum jubilee
celebrations this summer and she was
able to see
just how much she meant to us
elizabeth ii demonstrated the very best
of our british values and her leadership
she represented those values to the
world
she was our greatest export our greatest
leader
the greatest of britons
when her majesty the queen died this
afternoon in balmoral
a little piece of all of us here in
britain
died with her